- I drew on her back with my finger,
the letter I, and then
a heart, and then (sobs)
- Aww, that's so cute.
(soft music)
(Alex sobs)
- Do you want me to reverse
that question on you?
- No
(both laughing)
- No, no, no, no.
(soft upbeat music)
- Hi. How's it going?
- Hi. (laughs) Hi.
- My name's Alex.
Nice to meet you.
- Hi, I'm Krista.
- My name's Casey.
What's your name?
- Karen.
- Hi Karen.
(Karen laughs)
- Hi, my name's Jade.
- Nice to meet you.
I'm Michael.
- Hi, Michael.
- How are you doing, like really?
(soft music)
(bird chips)
Can you hear me?
- Yeah, I can hear you.
- Yeah.
- I'm doing better.
It's been really rough.
- Yeah.
- I'm just trying hard to hang on
and live by the notion
of it is what it is.
- Yeah.
- And no matter what happens to me
it's good because I'll learn from it.
Yeah. How about you?
How are you?
(Karen laughs)
- The same thing.
- Yeah.
It's been hard for everybody.
- Are you getting better?
- Yeah. I think with the growing up,
there's a lot of things
I need to work through
just things I need to
learn from, but it's hard.
- It's hard sometimes
'cause the world moves so fast.
- Yeah. (chuckles) Really.
- And we see other people being good
and getting it and we feel
like, why don't I get it?
- Yeah. Or like why can't I do that?
- We all have our moment,
we just have to be patient
and have faith that things
will work themselves out.
as long as we keep doing
the next indicated thing
and trying to help people and be kind.
- Yeah.
- Well, I'm looking at my, I
guess ex-girlfriend right now.
We still hang out as we're doing right now
and we still love each
other and we still...
(soft music)
- Okay.
- Sorry.
- So how are you feeling
about all that then?
- It is hard.
- Okay. I get that.
I get that.
- It's hard to move on.
Wow. I didn't know I was
gonna get (laughs) emotional.
Geez. How are you doing really?
(soft music)
- Today is a good day.
Not every day is a good day,
but today is a good day.
- Today's actually a
really, really good day.
Actually, the last couple
years have been really
really rough, too, but
today's been really great.
So (laughs) yeah.
And I think it's on the up and up.
- What's causing you hardship?
- I think the thing
that's hurting me the most
is my parents are immigrants,
they've just been finding
the immigration process,
that's a long time.
- Yeah.
- And I think that's the one thing
that's kind of always
on my mind right now.
- Do you live with them?
- Yeah.
- Do you take care of them?
- Yeah. And they kind of had me
when they were kind of older.
- Yeah.
- So I want them to be able to
have that before they leave.
- Yeah.
- They just wanna go back
to where they came from
before they pass away.
- Yeah.
- And I feel like the
one thing that helps me
every day is that when people
at work that are Mexican
they come in and I can translate for them.
That's something that kind of grounds me
back to knowing that I can help them.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- What's something I
wouldn't believe about you?
- Wouldn't believe?
- Yeah.
- This one just came to mind.
I'm kind of short, but
I'm good at basketball.
(both laughing)
- Okay. Okay.
This one always gets people
is that I've broken each arm five times.
- Five times.
(Jade laughs)
- Yeah.
- Doing what?
- Fallen off playgrounds,
snowboarding, skateboarding.
- Okay. So your whole life?
- Yeah, just being reckless.
( man chuckles)
(Karen laughs)
- One time I had to go
home in kindergarten
'cause one of my friends
bite my butt cheek
so hard.
- What?
(Karen laughs)
I actually believe that.
- Why?
- 'Cause I don't think
you would make that up.
(Karen laughs)
(dog barks)
- What's something I
wouldn't believe about you?
- I'm fully fluent in Spanish.
I can read it, write it,
speak it, understand it.
I learned Spanish as a language
before I learned English.
And I'm pretty much as white boys, I guess
(Karen laughs)
genetic white guy
but most people don't believe it.
And then when I throw it out there
I always get really like ghost looks
or like big eyes, like, "Oh my goodness.
"He said that?"
(Karen chuckles)
My grandmother who raised
me, she was my mom.
She wanted to buy a house here
in San Diego and opened
up a bed and breakfast.
And she felt that it was
important for me to learn Spanish
because there's a lot of
Spanish speakers in San Diego.
And so I went to a school,
it was a magnet school.
Everything was in Spanish.
So I learned a lot about the Incas
the (mumbles) the Mayans
and all those groups
more than I learned
about American history.
- I'm glad.
- I wouldn't trade it for the world.
I really appreciate the fact
that I can speak both languages.
It's something I really cherish a lot.
- Yeah.
- Next question.
What is your biggest insecurity?
- The first one I think
of is the way I talk
and you probably can't
tell from this interview
I'm actually kind of proud of myself
for keeping a conversation going.
And so my biggest insecurity
is I mumble and I fumble
on my words and I have
these big ideas in my head
but I can't articulate them into words
and conversation and sentences.
And I know I'm so smart in my head,
but I can't get it out.
So maybe that's why I stay quiet a lot.
(soft music)
- I don't feel like intelligence routes
from being able to speak everything
that you want your ideas.
I mean, you could be the smartest person
and the quietest person.
- That's true.
- Also your voice sounds nice to me.
And if you have mumbled
or started or anything, I haven't noticed.
- No. Yeah. Actually, I'm really happy
with how I am...
Yeah. I don't know.
Maybe it's the surrounding the-
- Maybe it's just easier
to talk to a stranger.
- That's true. Yeah.
- Michael, what's your biggest insecurity?
- Oh, biggest insecurity.
My voice probably, it's kind of monotone
and I can mumble and not
speak up all the time.
So some days I'm okay at it
some days I'm really bad at it
and it's just kind of annoying
for the days whereas I just
can't get it to work right.
(Michael chuckles)
- Oh, well, if it's any console,
I thought your voice sounded nice.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah.
- What's your biggest insecurity?
- I feel like I just
don't like the way I look
that sounds cliche as a
girl, but I just don't.
- What is a song that reminds
you of someone you love?
(man sobs)
- I listen to a lot of music
and I attach emotions to songs.
- Me too.
- And when I listen to them
(Man sobs)
I like to think that I'm time traveling
in my mind to places.
And there's an artist called Laplux
and there's a song called "Without You"
(man sobs)
and my mom passed away
about a month before my daughter
was born and it killed me.
I was broken and this song
is something I heard during that time.
And I go to it just so that
I can feel that pain again
so I can feel something,
so I don't forget.
I feel like as time goes by,
she's drifting away from me.
(dog barks)
And so I really listen to that song
to try to still feel, even
though it's not necessarily
a good feeling, it's something
I'm sorry that I'm emotional.
- It's okay.
I really started crying
at the first question.
(Karen laughs)
- Yeah.
- I don't even know why.
- What about yourself?
- My dad's really (sobs)
my dad's really sweet.
When I went through my
(mumbles) teen phase
I was listening to like Led Zeppelin
and he would always
play in the living room.
He always listened to "Stairway to Heaven"
and I'm pretty sure it's
the only song he knows.
'Cause me and my dad
are been very similar,
we don't talk a lot, but we
do a lot kind of non-verbally.
And I feel like a lot of the times,
he just plays music in the
living room to comfort me
- Probably he cares a lot about you.
- Yeah.
- He probably thinks a lot about you
and how you're feeling.
I can relate just with my own daughter
with our situation and us moving
and it's abruptly and there's
a lot of changes going on
and I really worry about
how she's taking it.
- I have two songs,
"Blank Space" and "Style."
Not because they're
relatable in the lyrics,
but my sister and I,
we would do road trips from
Canada to San Diego a few times.
And there was one road
trip where the only song
in her phone was "Blank Space."
And then SiriusXM Radio wasn't working
but they kept on playing "Style" so-
- "Blank Space" like-
- By Taylor Swift.
like Taylor Swift?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- (laughs) Okay.
- And then "Style" is the other one.
So we just went back and forth
- That's so funny.
for a 20 hour drive
with those two songs.
- Oh my God.
- Tell me about your first love
and why did you fall in love with them?
- Damn, I'm gonna get emotional again.
(Krista laughs)
Well, I'm looking at
her like I said earlier.
- Aww.
You can take your time.
It's okay.
- Thank you.
I've always been pretty
independent/introverted
and I never had a desire
to be with someone.
Angel came around outta nowhere.
We clicked, and I told her I loved her
in the first month.
And I don't think I told her actually,
now that I'm remembering it.
I drew on her back with my finger,
the letter I, and then a heart
and then it...
(Krista sobs)
- Aww, that's so cute.
(Alex sobs)
- You doing okay?
- It is good to talk about this
and it's good to let it out.
- Yeah.
- It's good to tell the world, too
but also just to tell a stranger
and I know she's watching me right now
and tell her, too.
Do you want me to reverse
that question on you?
- No.
(both laughing)
- No, no, no, no.
No, no.
You're okay
- Man.
- [Woman] Are you okay?
- Ugly crying on camera.
(both laughing)
- You're okay.
- She's a good listener
and picks a good stranger.
(woman laughs)
- Thank you.
- Okay. Tell me a secret, Michael.
- A secret.
- Yeah.
- Geez. I don't know
if I have any secrets.
Let me think.
- I actually do have a secret to share.
I'm sorry, but deep down,
nobody knows this but I
wanna be able to sing karaoke
really well.
- Me, too.
- And I envision singing the song
and then everybody getting up and clapping
but I sound so horrible on a microphone.
And I see my blue car coming.
- [Woman] Okay.
- No.
- [Woman] Say something
kind about the other person
based on your conversation.
- You seem like a very
genuine, sincere person
that wants to help people.
And I hope that you're
able to stay focused
on that because everything
else is accessory,
it's all about our passions.
- Thank you.
- I notice that you're
really good at listening
and you heard me and you understood me.
So thank you.
- Thank you.
You have a very big heart.
You're definitely very full of love.
- Wow.
- And you have a lot of love
and a lot of kindness
and warmth inside of you.
You also cried a little bit,
so that's why I picked up on that one
'cause you're definitely,
definitely full of love.
- Well, you know what?
That really means a lot,
'cause besides maybe Angel
I don't think anyone's said that to me.
So that means a lot.
- Honestly this really made my day.
You're just such a cool person to talk to.
And I do like your voice by the way.
(both laughing)
- That all means a lot.
Yeah. Thank you.
I'll just say even though
I know I satisfied my part,
but my voice, if I felt like you're...
I really like your voice.
I know the headphones probably
make it sound really good,
but this is nice and smooth
and I really enjoyed
how much you opened up
about your family and your past.
It was a fun conversation.
Yeah, definitely.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Whenever you're ready,
you can definitely turn.
(dog barks)
(Karen laughs)
- How's it going?
- Hi.
(both laughing)
- How are you?
- Good.
- It's nice to see you.
- Yeah, it was fun.
- Yeah, it was.
This is really cool.
- Yeah.
(both laughing)
- Hi.
- Nice to meet you.
- Me, too.
- Was it...
We talked so much.
Was it Krista?
- Yes.
Oh, wow. Great.
- Alex.
- Yes.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- Nice to meet you.
- Every time I watch my interview videos,
I was like if I'm in
Balboa Park and I see her
I'm gonna act like I don't know her.
- Glad you did it.
- So I'll do it.
But no, (laughs) I couldn't hold it in.
I was like, I know you.
I know who you are.
I was like, please still take me.
- Wait. Angel, do you
mind getting in this?
I'm sure everyone's curious.
- Yes.
- Gets over here.
- That was the second thing.
- Oh wait, (mumbles)
- What?
- Come here.
- Hello.
(both laughing)
- This is my angel.
(soft upbeat music)
- Hey everyone, Thoraya here.
I wanted to say thank you
for watching this episode.
I am still selling these
sweaters on my website.
If you're interested,
I'll link it in my description.
I love you guys.
And I'll see you next week.
(soft upbeat music)